e quando uma mãe é meio querida e bem
cuidada durante a gestação grandes são
as chances de seu bebê nascer saudável
de ter um crescimento normal por outro
lado a gente sabe que uma mãe de
qualquer espécie ao passar por algum
tipo de restrição alimentar ou até mesmo
a superalimentação vai trazer
consequências negativas ao filho gerado
as deficiências nutricionais nas
gestantes podem levar a alterações tanto
no organismo materno quanto do
recém-nascido alteração no seu estado
nutricional pode levar à anemia a
hemorragias ao ganho de peso inadequado
ao parto prematuro e pode deixar
sequelas para uma vida inteira qualquer
semelhança com a mãe natureza não é mera
coincidência a gente tá ligado a ela
quase como um bebê tá ligado à mãe pelo
cordão umbilical o que esperar então os
filhos se a mãe Terra estiver doente mal
nutrida receber
os resíduos do que ela pode suportar com
dificuldades para respirar
e levando em conta que alimento é aquilo
que mantém que sustenta aquilo usado
como fonte de matéria e energia para
realização das funções vitais o que cabe
a nós fazer hoje para que as futuras
gestações da nossa mãe Terra Gere filhos
saudáveis filhos que vão tocar o futuro
da humanidade
Ah e por falar em futuro ele pode ser
caótico o abundante vai depender do
quanto a gente já compreendeu que a
velocidade das mudanças da exponencial
eu não sei se você já se deu conta mas a
situação Global vai ser
consideravelmente diferente no futuro ao
analisar a quantidade de alimentos
produzida hoje em comparação a 1960 a
gente observa o volume 3 vezes superior
na mesma área de terra Esse aumento
expressivo da produção ele reflete
diretamente na nutrição da população
é mas será que isso representa tudo o
que a gente pode fazer de melhor no
futuro terá que aumentar a quantidade de
quilos produzidos na mesma área de antes
e a saída que resume o futuro da
produção de alimentos será que ainda
assim será insuficiente EA gente vai ter
que partir para fonte Alternativa de
energia
bom então antes de falar do futuro eu te
convido a resgatar um pouco do nosso
passado a troca de massa e energia entre
os seres vivos eo ambiente físico
acontece há milênios ela formam um
sistema Ecológico ou também chamado de
ecossistema considerado um sistema
estável equilibrado autossuficiente
apresentando em toda a sua extensão
características topográficas climáticas
pedológicas botânicas e zoológicas
geológicas geoquímica Praticamente em
variáveis
é mas a alteração de um único elemento
costuma causar modificações em todo o
ecossistema podendo levar à perda desse
mágico equilíbrio Dessa forma não seria
incoerente falar do alimento do Futuro
sem mencionar que a humanidade enfrenta
desafios sem precedentes referente à
incapacidade desses ecossistemas
sustentarem as atividades econômicas
contemporâneas
É sim a proteína de fonte vegetal a
cultura de células o consumo de insetos
vão crescer mas a gente não pode
esquecer que a população como um todo
também vai aumentar o desafio que de
todos o desafio de alimentar cerca de
dez bilhões de pessoas em muito pouco
tempo então não tem saída quando a gente
pensa no alimento do futuro vai ser
preciso continuar produzindo proteína
animal mas não do mesmo jeito e para
produção continuar arruma o que o mundo
deseja e precisa ver a gente vai ter que
mudar o pensamento de que não tem uma
única solução mágica e Como disse Jake
bobo não precisamos de uma única solução
mas de todas elas assim a gente vai ser
capaz de deixar um planeta melhor para
as futuras gerações
Hum será que então ainda temos chance
hoje a gente está conduzindo a nossa
sociedade como se a gente fosse máquina
e a gente não é máquina é errado a gente
se basear em que a gente é separado a
ideia de que a humanidade é separada de
todas as outras espécies é além de tudo
perigosa se eu pudesse eleger um dia que
o núcleo do problema da atualidade é a
separação entre a humanidade eo mundo
natural e também a crença de que a
economia é a coisa mais importante das
nossas vidas
E esses são as ações do homem que tem o
potencial de alterar os diferentes
ecossistemas
e não seriam elas que precisariam ser
estudadas são elas que precisam ser
discutidas criticadas então mudadas
visando a conscientização dos indivíduos
a respeito das consequências das suas
ações ou morreremos ou a gente se
reinventa de uma forma que seja
sustentável Eu quero dizer é que ou
teremos mudanças radicais ou a
humanidade corre sérios riscos de 6
tintas
Hum será então que ainda temos chance
e como é que a carne bovina pode ser
parte do alimento do futuro e suprir as
demandas do novo mano
É eu sei por mais contra-intuitivo que
possa aparecer para compreender essa
aparente contradição eu trago dois
conceitos interligados entre si One
Health ou saúde única e Agricultura
regenerativa
é a evolução de sustento do nosso
planeta dependem de uma relação
simbiótica entre humano animal e meio
ambiente que a gente compartilha a gente
está interconectado não tem jeito
acontece aqui no século passado o
domínio humano sobre a biosfera se
manifestou em inovações tecnológicas de
uma forma tão acelerada que os
ecossistemas convertidos se
caracterizaram alguma industrialização a
globalização EA urbanização ser
protagonista dessa parte da história
traz a necessidade de uma abordagem de
cunho efetivo no conceito de saúde única
a interface então existente entre homem
animal e meio ambiente está sendo
reconhecida internacionalmente como uma
tendência efetiva o gerenciamento de
doenças emergentes e de novas pandemias
de origem exótica
e o conceito an Health reconhece então
afirma e também acredita no a
interconexão fundamental que existe
entre todas as formas de vida saúde
humana animal e ambiental são
indissociáveis a existência dessa Tríade
forma a homeostase entre as ações
existentes estão essenciais para
garantir o futuro saudável e sustentável
do equilíbrio e Vida no nosso planeta
terra onde está com o benefício
sinérgico de uma cooperação mais
estreita entre as ciências humana animal
e ambiental bem como a importância de
Desfazer os Muros disciplinares e
profissionais entre elas o aparente
domínio da espécie humana sobre as
demais espécies vem com uma enorme
responsabilidade portanto em nossa busca
para garantir saúde alimento e continuar
existindo enquanto humanos a gente
precisa levar em consideração essa
complexa entre
a interdependência de todas as espécies
vivas e do meio ambiente a gente tem
conhecimento de que quase toda decisão
humana causa consequências indesejadas e
humanos animais e meio ambiente não são
sistemas complexos separados porque a
gente não consegue então Minimizar os
impactos causados pelo humano
e a resposta que me parece mais adequada
é que nenhum de nós nem eu nem você tem
a capacidade cognitiva instintiva para
tomar decisões que reflitam essa
complexidade o nosso processo simples de
tomada de decisão não evoluiu para
refletir que agora a gente gera uma rede
enormemente complexa com dimensões
sociais e ecológicas econômicas e isto
resultou no nosso processo de tomada de
decisão básico causando uma reação em
cadeia negativa por todas as dimensões
dessa rede complexa
e nós não notamos definitivamente que
não é o consumo de carne bovina o vilão
é o nosso processo de tomada de decisão
a causa da devastação Global porque não
ato de cada decisão nosso frequentemente
atingimos nossos objetivos a curto prazo
e aí a gente segue adiante só mais tarde
os animais as pessoas as plantas as
economias vão sofrer as consequências
indesejadas e nesse momento nós usamos o
mesmo processo de tomada de decisão
ultrapassado para reagir ou adaptar
essas consequências então aqui o reforço
não o consumo de carne não é o vilão
muito pelo contrário ele pode e vai ser
parte da solução da complexidade das
decisões que vão precisar ser tomadas a
gente quiser continuar existindo
ó e aqui que eu dou destaque é o segundo
conceito que evidencia o papel Vital do
gado na reversão da mudança climática e
da desertificação do planeta
e o gerenciamento holístico é uma
ferramenta de gestão criada por ela não
sei ver um produtor rural e Doutor em
ecologia do Zimbabwe para que Produtores
Rurais pudessem ser produtivos sem que
isso comprometer-se a qualidade de vida
EA saúde ecológica das suas propriedades
essa abordagem entre as contribuições
importantes para alfabetização ecológica
daqueles que se propõem a trabalhar
dentro do paradigma da Agricultura
regenerativa especificamente agricultura
regenerativa é uma prática holística de
manejo da terra que aproveita o poder da
fotossíntese nas plantas para fechar o
ciclo de carbono e construir a saúde do
solo a resiliência das culturas EA
densidade de nutrientes
e ela então uma abordagem aos sistemas
alimentares e agrícolas que Visa a
regenerar o solo aumentar a
biodiversidade melhorar os ciclos da
água melhorar os serviços dos
ecossistemas apoiar o Bios sequestro tão
falada mundo afora aumentar a
resiliência a pontuação climática e
fortalecer a saúde vitalidade do solo
reciclando assim o máximo do lixo
agrícola bem como adicionando o material
de compostagem de fora da Fazenda Ah mas
certamente para que tudo isso aconteça o
potencial produtivo vai precisar ser
reduzido E aí a conta não fecha
e apesar desse questionamento você parte
do processo simples de tomada de decisão
do humano é aí que vem a melhor parte
idealmente numa propriedade regenerativa
de manejo holístico a produção deve
crescer ao longo do tempo à medida que o
solo se a profunda os rendimentos podem
aumentar e os insumos externos de
compostagem diminui só que nem tudo são
flores as pessoas que se propõe a
empreender na agricultura regenerativa
enfrentam diversos desafios políticos
econômicos e culturais
e dentre as dificuldades causadas por
paradigmas culturais a gente pode citar
três mais recorrentes primeiro deles é o
complexo de herói depois a gente tem as
tendências objetivas e o hábito de
colocar os objetos acima da qualidade de
vida vamos começar então complexo de
herói ele vem dá certeza que a gente tem
que é necessário tornar O agronegócio EA
sociedade de consumo obsoletos antes que
juntos destruam todo o planeta e com ele
seres humanos a consciência de urgência
Então faz a gente sacrificar muitas
coisas em prol dessa missão digna e
necessária já as tendências de
confirmação fazem com que a gente tem
que buscar informações olha que louco
que confirmem as nossas crenças E aí a
gente descarta as evidências que
confirmam conclusões contrárias ao
diferentes em resumo faz com que ao
invés da gente buscar evidência para
depois formar uma opinião a gente busca
evidência
Bom dia minhas opiniões que a gente já
tem cômodo né olha o cão perigoso
limitante as paradigma já o hábito de
colocar os objetivos acima da qualidade
de vida é fruto de um dualismo
reducionista do modelo de civilização
ocidental Em uma sociedade cada vez mais
competitivo e materialista o que a gente
conquistou se tornou mais importante do
que como vivemos e isso traz muitas
consequências negativas inesperadas e
sabe que tenham mais interessante que os
dois conceitos são ancorados na mesma
base
é o que fazemos individualmente
realmente afeta o ambiente em geral tudo
que a gente administra envolve
organizações humanas e natureza ambas
definidas como sistemas complexos que se
auto-organizam e a nossa incapacidade
então de administrar o que é complexo e
tá afundando a humanidade por isso a
gente deve lembrar que a base da
natureza humana é a cooperação se a
gente para para observar como os
sistemas complexos se auto-organiza na
natureza há milênios
ou será que não tem algo que a gente
humano pode aprender com ela na forma de
produzir alimentos no futuro
é a minha esperança que sim e quando a
gente se der conta que a gente ainda
ligado que a gente faz parte do todo a
gente vai tender a se comportar de uma
forma diferente incluindo a forma se
alimentar mas nada disso é novidade a
gente já sabe disso há muitos e muitos
anos a gente deixou esquecido talvez a
confluência de tecnologia da comunicação
tenha nos trazidos à tona mas o
propósito humanista não pode ser
substituída por nenhum meio nem a maior
Ou melhor das tecnologias do presente ou
desse futuro que vão ser descobertas por
nós mesmos os humanos falhar em ver
qualquer coisa boa do outro lado torna o
diálogo impossível e sem diálogo a gente
vai continuar repetindo os mesmos erros
porque a gente não aprendeu nada de novo
moral da história esse nosso de cal esse
ideal o sistema de criação de bovinos no
pasto pode ser uma das soluções para
combater o aquecimento global uma vez
que a interação dos animais herbívoros
com as gramíneas faz com que o solo seja
melhor capturando muito
o carbono e aumentando a capacidade do
Sol de armazenar água então a isso que
chamam sustentabilidade não é melhor do
que ela prática sustentável por
definição procura a manter o mesmo
Enquanto as práticas regenerativas
reconhecem que os sistemas naturais
estão afetados e aplicar técnicas de
gerenciamento para restaurar o sistema e
essa precisa ser a nossa saída
e para encerrar eu gostaria de dar um
recado especialmente as mulheres
e a nossa sociedade é masculinizada
portanto os valores femininos tem sido
esquecidos e eu não tô falando aqui só
dos homens não nós mesmas as próprias
mulheres temos abandonado os valores
femininos para encontrar um lugar à luz
a gente deixou de nos encontrar no
espaço e isso é muito problemático não
só para gente mas para a sociedade uma
crise como esta que nós vivemos
globalmente tem muito a ver com limite
de egoísmo que a gente chegou por isso
valores femininos como a generosidade a
exemplo da capacidade de gerar e dar
vida a capacidade de doação a
característica de olhar o detalhe o
Requinte tem muito a ver com as
necessidades da vida no futuro com
humano do futuro com o tipo de alimento
que consumimos no futuro que possamos
resgatar esses valores
o e trabalhar em complementaridade
sermos generosos com uma mãe que gera a
vida assim desejar nada em troca coragem
vem decore coração herói vende Eros deus
do amor e humano do futuro seja mais
coração e amor que tenhamos coragem para
enfrentar os desafios e que estejamos
heróis para o nosso planeta e por falar
dela para livro da nossa mãe terra o
alimento do Futuro Pode sim continuar
vindo do seu ventre do seu solo do nosso
complexo ecossistema sem que qualquer
bife Deixe de ser produzido mas para
isso "a humanidade precisará de uma nova
forma de pensar se quiser sobreviver"
frase do nosso querido Albert Einstein
muito obrigada tá